we were building dualingo for cooking
with zest people come into the app
itself they take a skill assessment
which places them in a level so say they
want to cook a soup they might cook our
Thai curry soup they'll learn things
like the way that you cut your
ingredients actually impacts the way
they cook cleaning as you go is a really
important part of the cooking process if
they want to cook a soup they might cook
our beef Ramen and they'll learn about
the science behind flavor extraction and
infusion the idea behind concentrating
flavors the reduction raising a meat in
a flavorful liquid now that's like the
basic skeleton of how people use this
their lives around food are totally
changing they cook four times a week
save over $500 a month and get to take
care of the people that they care about